[Aplausos]
[Música]
seguro que la mayoría de vosotros habéis
escuchado hablar del proceso de
impeachment contra donald trump sin
embargo cuántos de nosotros sabemos
realmente que es en qué consiste y cuál
es la historia de los procesos de
impeachment en eeuu porque amigos ya os
adelanto que este proceso es mucho
muchísimo más complejo que un mero
debate sobre la destitución del
presidente
[Música]
la constitución americana define el
impeachment como una herramienta de
máxima excepcionalidad con ella el poder
legislativo puede revertir en la
práctica la voluntad del pueblo una
voluntad que se expresa con la elección
del presidente por este motivo el
impeachment supone en circunstancias muy
serias la negación del régimen electoral
democrático
hablamos de un proceso pensado para
casos en los que el presidente haya
cometido delitos graves delitos que
deben ser claramente demostrados tras
una minuciosa investigación previa en la
cámara de representantes- estos delitos
son fundamentalmente casos de traición
soborno y otros crímenes o delitos
graves que no están especificados
pero amigos incluso con esta explicación
todavía me faltan cosas muchas cosas
para entender del todo cómo funciona
este proceso del impeachment no nos
parece por eso en este vídeo no sólo os
vamos a hablar a fondo de este curioso
proceso sino que también vamos a echar
un vistazo a la historia y vamos a
contaros cuántos impi ximena ha habido
en eeuu porque sucedieron y cómo
terminaron y si como no también vamos a
ponernos al día sobre el impeachment
contra el presidente de los eeuu donald
trump atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el impeachment un contrapeso clave en la
democracia estadounidense es que se
diseñó pensando estrictamente limitar el
poder de los políticos veréis me explico
lo curioso en el caso de eeuu es que
tanto la constitución como la carta de
derechos son limitantes es decir si la
ley es no os costará daros cuenta de que
en realidad lo que dice sirve
básicamente para evitar que el estado o
las personas que controlan el estado
ejerzan un excesivo poder sobre el resto
de los ciudadanos
esto es algo que supone una diferencia
muy pero que muy importante respecto a
la mayoría de constituciones del resto
del mundo que se centran en definir los
derechos y obligaciones de los
ciudadanos y esto amigos es algo clave
fundamental esencial para comprender el
significado de un impeachment en los
eeuu
los padres fundadores establecieron
desde un principio la posibilidad de
destituir al presidente y otros altos
cargos definieron el proceso como un
juicio político y no penal de este modo
el presidente puede ser apartado de sus
funciones por ciertos delitos graves sin
que ningún juez juzgue en ningún momento
del proceso
[Música]
de hecho el único juez presente durante
todo este proceso de impeachment es el
presidente de la corte suprema que se
encarga de ordenar el funcionamiento del
juicio político una vez este pasa al
senado pero la sentencia la destitución
es decidida única y exclusivamente con
la votación de los senadores
sin embargo llegados a este punto puede
que muchos estáis pensando pero vamos a
ver si esto es un proceso político
entonces se podrá utilizar para ir en
contra de cualquier presidente que nos
guste a la oposición verdad pues lo
cierto es que no eso no es posible bajo
el sistema norteamericano
[Música]
para evitar que algo así ocurra se
establecieron una serie de complicados
pasos que garantizan que solo un proceso
de impeachment muy justificado llegue no
sólo a completarse sino incluso a
iniciarse
tanto es así que hasta la fecha en los
casi 250 años de historia de los eeuu
todavía no se ha producido ni un solo
imprime en efectivo ni uno solo es más
en todo este tiempo tan solo se han
iniciado dos bueno tres si tenemos en
cuenta el actual contra donald trump 3
en toda la historia
ahora bien como es entonces este proceso
que exactamente cuáles son los pasos a
tomar hasta la destitución de un
presidente fijaos
[Música]
lo primero que tiene que haber son
indicios prácticamente pruebas de que el
presidente podría haber incurrido en
algún supuesto de los que recoge la
constitución con esto cualquier miembro
de la cámara de representantes- tiene
que proponer el impeachment o juicio
político bajo juramento en el caso del
de trump ha sido la propia presidenta de
la cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
después designa a los comités que
investiguen el caso y determinen los
hechos que son imputables para el
impeachment finalmente estos comités
redactan uno o varios artículos que son
votados individualmente o en conjunto
por la cámara de representantes lo que
equivale a presentar cargos contra el
presidente
[Música]
es decir para que nos entendamos la
función en este caso de la cámara de
representantes- es presentar cargos si
lo hace entonces comienza propiamente el
impeachment o juicio político y todo el
proceso se transfiere al senado que es
quien juega el rol principal en toda
esta historia
[Música]
de hecho tal y como veis es en realidad
allí en el senado donde se produce
realmente el juicio político es el
senado la cámara que en este caso actúa
como si fuera un tribunal un juzgado
pero en lugar de jueces fiscales y
jurado lo que nos encontramos aquí en
esta situación es con miembros de la
cámara de representantes que actúan como
fiscales y senadores que actúan como
jurados
[Música]
de esta forma si los senadores votan por
una mayoría de dos tercios a favor de la
destitución eso equivale a que en un
juicio normal el jurado declara culpable
al acusado y amigos esto en un
impeachment no significa otra cosa que
la destitución automática del presidente
y el traspaso de todos sus poderes al
vicepresidente
[Aplausos]
parece complejo en realidad lo es pero
es lógico pensad que tiene que ser un
proceso muy garantista para que no se
pueda destituir a un presidente así a la
ligera como quien se compra un bolso en
el black friday
[Música]
pero ahora bien después de saber cómo
funciona la otra gran pregunta que
podemos hacernos es que podemos aprender
de la historia de los juicios políticos
en los eeuu tal y como os hemos contado
quitando el de trump sólo encontramos
dos casos más en toda la historia el de
andrew johnson y el de bill clinton y
bueno el de richard nixon que en
realidad terminó en una dimisión
prematura y frente a lo que se suele
pensar nunca llegó a ponerse en marcha
pero queréis saber más sobre lo que
ocurrió en estos casos os lo contamos
[Música]
2 impeachment una dimisión y 0 de
instituciones la historia de los juicios
políticos en eeuu es breve muy breve tan
solo dos presidentes han sido sometidos
a él y ninguno de los dos fue destituido
quizás el caso que menos os suene es el
de andrew johnson y no es de extrañar
porque estamos hablando de un señor que
presidió el país entre los años 1865 y
pero qué hizo este hombre para acabar
siendo juzgado por el senador
norteamericano pues veréis tras el
asesinato del presidente lincoln en el
año 1865 este hombre que era su
vicepresidente se convirtió en
presidente y digamos que cuando tomó el
mando sus políticas se alejaron mucho de
las de lincoln vamos que empezó a volar
por libre y de qué forma
amigos para que os hagáis una idea
johnson era a la vez miembro del partido
demócrata y literalmente un supremacista
blanco convencido un tipo de lo más
racista vamos que al lado del trump
sería algo así como un férreo defensor
del multiculturalismo y la diversidad
[Música]
andrew johnson defendía firmemente la
esclavitud de los afroamericanos y se
dedicó a vetar todos y cada uno de los
proyectos de ley que el congreso
aprobaba para reconocer derechos a los
esclavos liberados también empezó a
indultar a generales de los estados
confederados de américa que para los que
no lo sepáis se rebelaron contra los
eeuu iniciando la guerra de secesión
[Música]
estos estados los estados que se
rebelaron consideraban que el lincoln
era una amenaza a la supremacía blanca y
que tenía un plan para abolir la
esclavitud en todo el país y esto esto
no sentaba nada bien por allí y ojo
porque algunos de estos estados tenían
un 49 por ciento de población esclava
casi nada
[Música]
pero si esto ya nos parece grave
esperanza ver la gota que colmó el vaso
johnson tuvo la genial idea de empezar a
cesar y nombrar a secretarios de su
gobierno saltándose la necesaria
validación del congreso lo que como os
podéis imaginar es del todo ilegal pero
fijaos si es complicado destituir a un
presidente que a pesar de todas estas
graves acusaciones johnson se salvó por
un solo voto en el senado un solo voto
hizo que no se alcanzaran los dos
tercios se salvó por los pelos pero se
salvó y de hecho ésta fue con diferencia
a la vez que más cerca se ha estado de
destituir a un presidente el siguiente
intento llegó con richard nixon más de
un siglo después tras el famoso
escándalo del watergate en 1972
[Música]
resumidamente el caso watergate fue un
escándalo que envolvió al presidente y a
varios agentes de la cia en el espionaje
al partido demócrata allanaron su sede y
pincharon llamadas para obtener grandes
ventajas de cara a la reelección de
nixon como presidente después durante la
investigación se descubrió que las
escuchas ilegales habían sido
controladas directamente desde la casa
blanca lo que en julio de 1974
desencadenó en el inicio de un
impeachment contra el presidente
[Música]
de hecho queridos amigos de visual
político la cosa fue tan grave que nixon
se quedó literalmente solo y como además
no le interesaba que la investigación
fuera más allá no sea que aparecieran
asuntos más turbios porque nixon fue un
presidente muy pero que muy turbio tras
siete meses de deliberaciones dimitió
justo un día antes de que la cámara de
representantes votará iniciar el proceso
de modo que en realidad el mecanismo del
impeachment nunca se puso en marcha
[Música]
en la explicación inmediata investiga y
sensores martín en el que si se puso en
marcha fue el proceso contra clinton hay
clinton clinton como la ley o bill
clinton podemos decir que metió la pata
y lo que no es la pata hasta el fondo y
es que seguro que a muchos de vosotros
os suena el nombre de mónica lewinsky
[Música]
incluso puede que alguno suene más el de
bill clinton mismamente porque a finales
de los 90 estuvo en boca de todos el
affair el desliz los encuentros
extramatrimoniales entre la entonces
becaria monica lewinsky y bill clinton
sin que su mujer hillary se enterase
espero no os equivoquéis el motivo del
proceso de impeachment contra bill
clinton no fue que el presidente le
hubiera sido infiel a su mujer para nada
el motivo real o al menos con el que se
justificó el proceso fueron las mentiras
de clinton y sus presiones para que
otros alrededor suyo también mintieron
con qué fin con el de ocultar una
sórdida historia de amor que mezclaba
engaños y diversión a partes iguales en
pleno despacho oval
[Música]
ahora
es un profesor
gates
y creedme cuando os digo que en eeuu al
menos hasta la llegada de trama al poder
eso de que un presidente fuera pillado
mintiendo y obligando a otros a mentir
era algo que no sabía nada pero que nada
bien
pero ya os hemos contado cuáles han sido
los impeachment y cómo funcionan pero y
trump qué pasa contra pues amigos ahora
le toca a él y lo cierto es que las
cosas no pintan o no deberían pintar muy
bien porque todo apunta que lo que ha
hecho es muy pero que muy grave
ahora bien en qué consisten exactamente
las acusaciones contra el presidente de
los eeuu puede este proceso afectarle de
cara a 2020 atentos
un gran baile en ucrania una jugosa
trama
amigos el caso de trump viene de lejos
concretamente desde nada más y nada
menos que ucrania pero qué narices tiene
que ver tram con ucrania y que pinta joe
biden en el título de este bloque
i
y es que veréis todo apunta a que trump
y dio directamente por teléfono al nuevo
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
que investigase a los bailes por sus
relaciones con la empresa de gas turismo
de cuya junta forma parte hunter maiden
el hijo de joe biden ex vicepresidente
de barack obama y uno de los futuribles
candidatos demócratas a la casa blanca
poco antes de esta llamada trump congeló
casi 400 millones de dólares en ayuda
militar a ucrania aparentemente como
método de presión y podría ser
considerado un soborno a cambio de un
favor un quid pro quo
[Música]
pero esto no se queda aquí incluso el
propio embajador de eeuu ante la unión
europea ha reconocido haber recibido
presiones de trump para forzar al
gobierno ucraniano a que investigase una
supuesta teoría por la que ucrania
habría interferido en las elecciones
presidenciales americanas de 2016 y no
está viendo el favor de trump como se
dice que hizo rusia sino a favor de
hillary y ya os podéis imaginar cómo son
las investigaciones en ucrania sobre
todo cuando se ponen en marcha por
presiones de washington
en otras palabras para que todos nos
entendamos parece que donald trump está
utilizando los medios y los recursos del
gobierno de los eeuu para presionar a
gobiernos de países con un estado de
derecho más que cuestionable para que
hagan por el el trabajo sucio contra sus
contrincantes de locos
ante estos graves hechos el congreso
decidió abrir un proceso de impeachment
para investigar minuciosamente todo este
asunto y saber si el presidente trump
soborno a los ucranianos para lograr su
material de campaña y ahí no termina
todo
según parece donald trump podría haber
creado una especie de diplomacia
paralela con ucrania fuera de las vías
institucionales a través de su abogado
personal
rudy giuliani obligando incluso a gordon
sound land a subordinarse a él
[Música]
ahora bien es esto suficiente para
tumbar al presidente no lo sabemos pero
lo que sí sabemos es que no paran de
salir más y más informaciones que
complican la situación de trump
informaciones como esta nuevos
documentos revelan detalles del papel de
pompeo en el asunto de ucrania los
correos electrónicos y documentos
publicados por el departamento de estado
respaldan el testimonio que muestra que
el secretario de estado mike pompeo
permitió la campaña de presión ucraniana
en el centro del proceso de juicio
político de todas formas lo cierto es
que al menos de momento el partido
republicano no parece favorable a dar la
espalda al presidente bajo las
acusaciones actuales y mucho menos
cuando queda tampoco para las elecciones
políticos
[Música]
aunque esto es algo que podría cambiar
si se dispara lo que en eeuu conocen
como una pistola humeante es decir una
información 100% contrastada probada y
explosiva como para ver un bar al
presidente
[Música]
pero hasta que eso pase y si pasa lo
normal es que con el respaldo
republicano donald trump mantenga la
presidencia recordad que en el senado
que es donde se decide la destitución
los republicanos tienen la mayoría la
única esperanza hoy por hoy para los
demócratas sería encontrar pruebas
flagrantes de que tras realmente soborno
las autoridades ucranianas para que
hicieran todo esto sin duda todo un
culebrón estaremos atentos a ver cómo se
desarrolla todo este embrollo pero ahora
ahora es vuestro turno para saber cómo
funciona impeachment cuántos ha habido y
por qué se produjeron que es que trump
tiene posibilidades de ser destituido o
terminará este proceso en un nuevo
impeachment fallido que os parece el
proceso de juicio político como
contrapeso al poder de los presidentes
dejando nuestros comentarios aquí abajo
y ya sabéis si os ha gustado este vídeo
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
al canal si aún no lo habéis hecho y una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
es profundizar
rodajas de honor en el world and its